no one in these huge UN camps is taking
anything for granted there are constant
patrols to ensure the safety of the
thousands of people living here behind
barbed wire everyone going in or out of
these camps is searched and checked a
ceasefire may have been declared but no
one quite believes it yet so even inside
the camp there are crucial precautions
everyone subjected to random searches
they've been attacks in the past inside
these safe havens I think they need some
time to realize or to to gain the
feeling of peace is actually coming so
it will be safe for them to return home
to their states where they originally
came from hundreds of babies have been
born behind these fortresses they know
no other life there are now multiple
schools inside the camps after whole
communities fled the violence here and
begged the UN for help these are some of
the students coming back to camp under
armed guard after exams even children
aren't safe the different militia are
still forcibly recruiting them peace
deal or no peace deal and the UN's
furious with this warning to those
involved in the ceasefire absolutely
stop it you have to live up to your
words and many of these people that I've
spoken to will say no no no we're not
doing it well if we find you are we will
name you and we will call you out for
what you were doing and we will take
that through a proper process because
these kids are more valuable than the
reputations of senior leaders cheol-yong
was among the hordes who ran for their
lives she tells us she lost six of her
seven children in the
Nick oh god amber oh seven children
seven children you've only got one with
you the restaurant separated Owen I got
a function well do this you don't know
whether you like so many others who are
learning new skills in the camps there's
hope this peace deal holds where others
have failed before but the peace is in
name only so far and the tens of
thousands of civilians who've been
displaced by this ongoing war are not
prepared to leave these camps or give up
the protection of the UN peacekeepers
who are ensuring their safety
thousands are surviving on aid delivered
by boat the world's youngest nation may
be rich in oil but it's people are some
of the poorest and many terrified
communities fled to remote areas
reachable only by water and tens of
thousands are dependent on this Aid four
and a half million people have been
displaced by the fighting in South Sudan
it's one of the highest displacement
crises on the planet and those we spoke
to told us the violence is still going
on
rapes and killings are still happening
so they won't be going home just yet we
don't feel like to go home now because
they the same attacks are still they
even though the euro this time for those
who've never known peace there is hope
but there's a long way to go before
there's real security here
Alex Crawford Sky News sound sit down